[Music]
yes you are one of the most honest
celebrities I've ever talked to you were
so honest about other celebrities you
haven't encounter and a lot of us we
know we bump into celebrity we have a
bad encounter we don't maybe mention it
you listen I'm a regular guy what you
see is what you get okay
I'm at a charity event okay beautiful
kids charity big people are there Eli
Manning all these celebrities all kinds
of sports guys Reggie Jackson you know
Reggie Jackson Reggie Jackson what
afraid of all time yeah so I go up to
him I says hello Reggie I had met him
the year before briefly I got a buddy of
mine
I said Reggie would you mind taking a
picture with my friend he goes yeah okay
hurry up little rude little rude I said
listen my name is Steve I met you last
year and he goes oh yeah
I remember you now real sarcastic yeah
makes me feel like an ass to be honest
for you you know I'm embarrassed so a
security guard comes over to me he says
listen that Reggie's a nasty guy and I
saw what he did to you listen to this he
hoped my friend owned the restaurant in
the 70s and he came in and he was nest
you know every this is when he was the
biggest spit star base he said his nest
said everyone in the restaurant so he
ordered a shrimp cocktail and the guys
in the back shoved them up their butts I
then put them back in the plane and they
all watched him eat the shrimp cocktail
so he said I just wanted to tell you
that story maybe it'll make you feel
better and I said well it really doesn't
make me feel better kind of disgust me
but now that I think about it it does
kind of make me feel good and if you go
out to dinner with Reggie Jackson if you
ever happen to don't share the shrimp
[ __ ]
[Applause]
oh my god I can't believe that was told
on television I've never been this happy
in my life story that's the true story
and Wow okay what's all lawyer up now